fue una decisión unánime los jueces en
el caso de Fernando baezosa condenaron a
cadena perpetua a cinco de los ocho
jugadores de rugby que mataron a golpes
al estudiante de 18 años fueron
considerados autores de homicidio
agravado por alevosía los otros tres
recibieron una sentencia de 15 años
pero la familia considera que la
sentencia no da justicia
Porque eran equipos son equipos son
equipos y asesinaron a Fernando en
equipo
ya que no estábamos conforme eso es lo
que decía queríamos justicia a la
Argentina en un país tan rica pero
justicia es muy vacía y este tribunal
desde mi punto de vista tuvo clemencia
con tres acusados de una manera
irracional Ese es el ese va a ser el
motivo de nuestra de nuestra apelación
por su parte los ocho acusados pueden
apelar la sentencia Fernando báez Sosa
murió luego de una riña en una discoteca
entre su grupo de amigos y el de los
jóvenes que posteriormente lo atacaron
tras ser expulsados de la discoteca los
jugadores de rugby lo agredieron por la
espalda una vez fuera del recinto lo
golpearon hasta que cayó inconsciente y
una vez en el suelo le siguieron
propinando Golpes en la cabeza el
tribunal Consideró que el grupo había
planeado el ataque el caso suscitó una
ola de repudio en Argentina y Paraguay
de donde es oriunda la familia de báez
Sosa el juicio ha sido ampliamente
mediatizado tanto en el país como a
nivel internacional